hey what's up guys I'm here with Sam and
Hannah they are both experts in property
and also have a legal background and
there's been some massive changes
recently in the in the market in the
property Market particularly in Wales
and we're going to be talking about
those changes because they are huge so
if you are a property investor and you
are you have any properties in Wales you
need to watch this video till the end
also if you're considering ever buying
properties in Wales as I say they're
massively massively changing the rules
so I'm joined with Sam and also Hannah
so did you want to introduce yourself
briefly I mean Sam we've known each
other for many many years but it'd be
great to get a little bit of an idea
about who you are and then we can delve
into some of these new changes that are
coming in
absolutely yes obviously the changes are
pretty massive uh for for landlords and
so it's actually yeah opportunity of
sharing it between today Samuel uh yeah
I'm Sam Hawking property lawyer got a
law firm Sam Hook and property lawyers
in South Wales and
um yeah obviously we do a lot of work
for property investors we do all the
different types of deal structures uh
that investors would normally do so
we're heavily engaged within with
investors and obviously uh I'm concerned
about some landlords uh that sort of
bury their head in the sand
um with the changes I'm Keen to make
sure that people are fully understand
what they need to do and make it as
simple for people to comply as it can be
now I've got a large portfolio myself
and property developer and I'm I'm very
busy and as guilty as the next man
bearing ahead of this end uh initially
and uh and obviously you need to get
them out together which is what I've
been doing more recently
um
you're the guy cool man when I'm when
there's a change or something's
happening I'm thinking what's this or if
it's about something to do with
compliance
um obviously we've got a background in
law uh conveyance there you've done a
lot of work for us as well over the
years
um you know you're the guy I call it
it's great to see you've partnered with
Hannah and also you've got a new
initiative as well which we'll talk
about later Anna what's your background
and and what is it that you do
yeah hi So yeah thank you again for
having me on um so yeah my time with
carton um I've been in property for over
20 years
um I set up my own agency when I was 26.
um and going to property just a little
bit before then
um and yeah being obviously a landlord
myself and develop properties and I've
done shortlets I've had a short let
company sold that company and um but my
main
um my main passion has always been to
help landlords and our values are really
strong around compliance anyone who's in
Wales Swansea especially will know that
uh that MacArthur nettings is a best
practice agency and I take a lot of
pride in making sure that you know every
T is crossed and their eyes docked you
know it is we're all about making sure
that we're protecting our our landlord
clients through
um obviously excellent service but
compliance because it's the most
costly mistakes that you can make is
getting something wrong
um so the other side of things is that I
am a consultant trainer for rent smart
Wales so um and just to give everyone a
bit of background
um here in Wales all landlords have to
be registered and if you do any type of
letting activity such as managing the
property yourself you will need to have
a license and in order to have a license
you have to have a full uh full training
um so knowing that these laws were
coming in I mean it's called the renting
homes act 2016. so that just gives you
some idea of how long it's taken to
to come into fruition
um
we I I started uh helping out by
actually going to Vincent Wells and and
helping rentals by training them
um so yeah so I'm a trainer I'm a
landlord I'm avestor
um and uh yeah so and I'm I'm here to
really just spread the word about what
the changes are and how we can help even
further and I know very well about rent
smart because I
um had to do that test and get that
license just to have just just to own
one house in Wales so um yeah I mean if
you're a landlord in Wales it's not it's
not difficult to get a license I think
it cost me around 100 pounds
um but people is familiar with the Welsh
Market will know that but the the
massive change that's coming in it very
short notice given as well could you
talk about what that is because I was
astonished when I when Sam called me and
told me
um yeah you know what was happening I
was quite shocked so would you guys be
able to explain what it is and how it's
going to affect landlords in Wales
sure so um there are a couple of
fundamental changes uh so just again to
give a little bit of a background that
um
the contracts have changed so before
we're all used to having a short short
whole tenancy agreements ASDS or
contracts
um they're now called occupational uh
contracts so in the first breath you
kind of need to understand that the
format of the new occupational contracts
are standardized so that's one of the
things that the Welsh government wanted
to do was make renting Easier by
creating these standardized occupational
contracts so by that I mean like all of
the Clauses are there available for
anyone to download for free
but this is the model contract that's
online
and there are some Clauses that you
can't change they're called fundamental
Clauses and then there are supplementary
Clauses that you can change and you
can't just delete them and you need to
edit them in a specific way and I'm not
going to go into that they mean this
we're literally just scratching the
surface I have to give you a little bit
of background to understand what what
the problem is
um so
um and it's called an occupational
contract and written statement
and the written statement element are
are the Clauses so I'm just kind of
explaining this in like the most basic
of terms
there is a requirement so the the law
changed on the 1st of December last year
and all active tenancies at that time
on the 1st of December automatically
transferred into an occupational
contract
and we were wonderfully sort of thinking
well it's an automatic transition we
don't have to do anything that is what
everyone is kind of saying don't worry I
don't have to do anything right now
um but there will be a requirement for
you to have a written a statement within
a six-month period now that ends on the
1st of June and we were like well what
is this written statement that we have
to then provide and it's transpired when
reading through all of the guidance
notes so it's you know a link to view
the guidance and then another Link in
the guidance for how to to do it
and what they're saying is that this
written statement needs to be
in the format of the new occupational
contracts so you've got your fundamental
and your supplementary Clauses but it
needs to be a true reflection of what
the whole tenancy agreement was as of
the 1st of December so that's in history
now you can't change what was on that
day the terms in in your in your
contract so the guidance just says oh
just go through every clause in your IST
and decide is this a compatible Clause
with a fundamental or a supplementary
clause and you go through all the
fundamentals and all the supplementaries
and you match them to your AST
and
the penalty for not issuing and the word
I find most
um concerning is the word incomplete so
to uh not provide an Inc a complete
statement the compensation to the
tenants is two months rent is the value
of two months rent
so we're thinking oh
that's a costly mistake
um so that's that's
um the biggest change with contracts is
is that they're now occupational
contracts and we have this uh very very
imminent deadline of the 1st of June to
get these written statements issued
the second part
um that's also very important to
understand is about Property Standards
so that there are three key parts that
need to be met the first which happened
again on the first of December is carbon
um monoxide alarms have to be in every
room that has a fuel burning Appliance
that's that's mandatory if you don't
have that already the property is not
fit for human habitation the second one
is then um
that smoke alarms have to be installed
and they have to be Mains powered and
interlinked and you need to have a
satisfactory electrical safety
certificate an eicr but they are to be
done by the first of December this year
so we've got all of these different
dates going on
um in this in this transition period
but the most concerning and the most
thing right now is is that we've got 33
days left to make sure that all of our
current tenants if they were in the
property on the 1st of December last
year that we issue this written
statement
and this is only Wales
England or Scotland or Ireland
this is crazy so I mean it sounds
complicated
I mean I understand a lot about
properties I'd like to think I'm a
reasonably switched on guy but it sounds
a bit complicated and also two months
rent that's a lot because if you're if
the rents are Grand your profit might
only be 200 quid
so if you have to pay the tenant two
months rent that could effectively be
like a Year's profit there thereabouts
so okay so so if you're a landlord in
Wales now then what do you actually need
to do do you need to change the contract
do you just said what do you actually
have to do
well again there's a lot of confusion
about about what to do so I've had so
many landlords come to me and say
um should I just issue a new contract
well you can but that's not meeting the
requirements because issuing a new
contract is a a now and a future thing
you need to issue a written statement
for the past
um so and then
um
yeah and some people say well should I
just you to put them into another sort
of fixed contract or just give them like
a written statement like a statement
that's written saying your contractors
has changed to an occupational contract
it is literally the um the requirement
is to give like a 34 or 42 Page document
the model written statement as amended
to your AST to your tenants so why have
they done this what's the actual reason
behind changing so and do I ask the
contracts are they going to no longer
exist in Wales
they don't exist It's Already Done
they've gone as of the first of December
they've all gone yeah and they are now
occupational contracts so the written
statement is the legal
um the legal way of completing the
conversion so there's a bit of law don't
quote me what it is that has enabled the
Welsh government to do this
um and it is now for landlords to
complete the conversion
by telling the tenants you're new you're
in a new occupational contract
um but the terms of your occupation are
either written a statement
uh identical because you can't go back
in history and change the terms because
nobody had
any information about it at the time you
see because it's in the yeah in the past
Sam why are they doing this why are they
doing it they're doing it I think
because the government of Wales seem to
have a a a beer in their Bonnet about uh
best practice and being better than
England and and sort of being the
grandma group
I know that I know that but we've got so
many examples of of this you know 20
mile an hour speed limits
sprinklers in all new homes even if
there's a even if there's a door out of
each each room to the outside of a
bungalow you've still got to put
sprinklers in in every room the the the
rash government does have this sort of
being nib on it and to do this but but
there are a lot of good things at the
same time that will come out of this
it's not all bad
um I think the transition is going to be
um difficult as as any as any change is
difficult to adopt but once it's settled
in
um it's not all bad there's more
paperwork involved for landlords there's
more there's more compliance there's
more there's a there's a better paper
trail needed
what's what there's more there's more
safety checks that are required but that
that's not all totally bad you know in
the grand scheme of things it's
providing better accommodation Theory uh
to tenants and there are some really
good nuggets for landlords you know for
instance I've had a uh a tenant for
quite some time with with really bad
anti-social issues
and
um it's been difficult to get him out
but since this contract changed I was
able to serve in with notice
and apply to court immediately because
there's no notice period for serious
anti-social uh problem tenants
there's a shorter there's a short notice
period depending on the amount of areas
for rent areas
but if you want to get a tenant out just
because you want to kind of talent out
uh then the situation is much better for
tenants you have to give them a six
months notice rather than the
traditional two months notice that
section 21 would have would have enabled
you to do and you can't give the notice
to quit within the first six months so
in effect even if you're giving six
months tenancy agreements or six-month
occupational contracts now in Wales
um because you can't give them a notice
in the fixed period
and then the notice that you do give is
a six-month notice
that there's a minimum term if you like
of 12 months so long as the tenant is is
is keeping their side of the bargain
yeah
yeah what are the how does it work with
the victim tenants on with these new
contracts then I mean you mentioned
about anti-social talents can be evicted
very easily but what will be the what
will be the if they don't pay rent for
example I wouldn't say it's very easy
because you've still got to prepare a
comprehensive Court application and
you've still got to go through the court
application to get in order for
possession and if they don't move out
possession but it's but it's quicker
than what it was
previously which is which is which is a
positive thing
yeah
um and and so the again the amount of
the amount of arrears depends on the
notice periods so that will get uh a
little more
um complex but there are other benefits
as well I've had issues with tenants
just leaving
uh and and previously under the under
the law you'd have to you'd still be
required to go to court to get an order
for possession
uh before you can change the locks
um you know lots of landlords would
simply change locks and keep their
fingers crossed yeah
um I wouldn't comment if I've done that
that the Welsh law now says uh that you
can put notice you can serve notice on
the property uh wait for uh the 28 day
period of four week period
um and and then change the locks
and and uh and so again that's a very
positive step forward
um and and again I've had that situation
myself several times
and and uh I've always been reluctant
because obviously with my profession my
professional capacity I probably want to
do something which uh was contrary to
the law
yeah
um it could be professionally
embarrassing
if I was caught out
so again this is important so there's
pros and cons then cons and it's just a
case of if you're investing in Wales or
certainly if you live in Wales and your
and your whole portfolios in Wales it's
just something that a new system that
you need to learn yes yeah
I mean universal written statement
well actually is that exactly what does
that mean
so um
again so people who are watching this
who might know me and uh I'm quite an
outspoken person a very polite way but I
wasn't particularly happy with having to
do this for you know over 170 landlords
and properties that we manage and my own
as well because all diff all asts are
different so
um you know we might have some tenants
who who started with us eight years ago
and our contracts back then were
slightly different to the updates you
know every year we get
um our contracts updated
um and then you've got some landlords
who use an AST from W Smith's or an
agent set up for them you know every AST
is slightly different yeah so you know
this is one massive headache so I
started sort of putting my my concerns
out quite strongly
um and behind the scenes
um the company who I use training for
professionals who Supply us as an agent
and Supply agents all over the UK so
they're not just Welsh but they do all
other
um you know English contracts and
letters and notices Etc they were
working tirelessly behind the scenes I
think it was about 10 days straight
um and three of them working on it to
create a document that was a written
statement that would work universally on
any
a short whole tenancy agreement that
converted on the 1st of December
um so when they called me to say can I
have I got any use for this
I said oh my God yes if I can help every
single landlord in Wales with this
written Universal written statement
and then then I think my purpose in life
has been completed
um because title life is too short to be
trawling through Clauses of ASDS when
you know we've got three bank holidays
coming up in May there are better things
to be doing with our time uh than than
tooling through these documents
um so and it just sort of came into into
play just at the right time where I'd
also been writing some um courses to be
able to explain to landlords about the
written statements but also about all of
the other changes in just a really easy
simple to understand way
um which if I'm jumping the gun it's
just kind of the right time to say it
which is how the landlord Community was
was born it just all came together sort
of middle of February and the light bulb
just went off and we're like wow we
actually have something really valuable
here to help landlords um navigate
through through all of this so that's
what the universal one is is is the one
that has been amended professionally
if you've got 10 properties do you need
do you need one universal statement or
do you have to have ten
you have to have 10 different ones
because the rents are going to be
different for instance
um and each Universal written statement
is going to correspond with each AST so
it's it's on every
every property or every tenancy that you
have
and as Sam pointed out the other day
that you might have a HMO that has six
individual afcs in there so that's six
written statements that you need to do
um so it is a very time consuming thing
uh uh in that regard so whereas is we we
estimated it to be at least eight hours
if not longer for a landlord to complete
this on their own
um I tested it yet just yesterday
actually a landlord came in saying
I I don't think this is right I don't
think I've got this wrong I said it's
going to take you 15 seconds you write
the rent in there you attach your IST
and it's done that is your your legal
compliance box ticked some how would
this affect
um short stylex if you is that is that
totally separate presumably if you've
got that separate yes so the short stay
left so not someone's own or principal
name dwelling so this this is about
Prince remain driving sure and when you
reached out to me and told me
maybe about a month ago about the
landlord community and what you're
wanting to do and help landlords with
with their compliance specifically in
Wales
with these new changes and other stuff I
think what what exactly is the landlord
Community going to be doing is is it
just specifically this topic or is it
compliance in general or and who's
involved
so the uh it's it's Hannah and I it's
Hannah's baby if you like
um and when I got to know about uh what
Hannah was doing I wanted to get
involved I wanted to help uh to to to
reach the masses in in of landlords in
Wales uh because it's a really important
thing uh Hannah developed obviously in
her in her
um position as a trainer for rent smart
Wales she could see that that the
training
um although it's very comprehensive it
still leaves people scratching their
head thinking what exactly do I need to
do
yeah and so Hannah already put together
these these these training programs and
and uh you know she was she was hoping
to help as many as she could but but a
handful of landlords with his with his
training and sort of hand-holding uh and
uh and I think I managed to persuade her
to uh to make the training free so uh
all the training that she's done uh
we're giving out for free that's great
and uh and the only cost then is the
cost of the actual Universal written
statement
a very simple
um guide on how to complete it
uh as kind of mentioned you know if if
she's there with people that she knows
it's got the other information to hand
it could be seconds uh it should only
take them 10 minutes if they're doing it
it'll save you a lot of time presumably
having having a universal written
statement oh no loads of time but not
only that you know if if you're a
landlord with
um five properties
and and you've had tenancy agreements
from different places or you've had them
from the same place and I thought you've
had them at different times as Hannah
mentioned uh the agency uh asts would
get updated every year yeah so if if
you've had different tenancies at
different times even if they're from the
same place they're going to be different
you're gonna have to go through each
tenancy agreement and work out what the
written statement needs to be whereas by
getting one from the Reynold Community
you've got one written statement that
you just adjust for each tenancy that
you've got it makes five ones and yeah
and you use it many times you need to
yeah how much is it to get a statement
97 pounds
and the training that you offer does
does that uh with rent smart CPD points
does it do you get any points to do with
the training that you offer or uh
that's a really good question
um
um I we don't at the moment but it is
absolutely on our radar that our
training will do but there's a really
valid reason why it doesn't anyone who's
done the Top-Up CPD continue
professional development
um course that red smart Wells has
issued and actually again for for
landlords who have an active license it
is a legal requirement for your license
to have done the CPD by the 28th of
February I know there's still hundreds
of thousands of landlords still going
through this process
um that one day course or online course
depending on which one you do
um is only worth five CPD points so that
is um you know when I I run the the
training that's from 9am until 3 30 in
the afternoon with half an hour lunch
and we are slideshow slideshow slideshow
constantly going on these are all the
things that you need to know about the
new legislation it is so in-depth and so
overwhelming
um and so much you know valid stuff that
you need to know is only worth five CPD
points now if we put that into the
context of
um the course that you do for Universal
Credit which
um my tenancy manager said took her
about half an hour
that's 30 CPD points or 10 or 30
something so it is that they they there
isn't the balance
so because my videos are between sort of
five and 20 minutes long and I'm really
taking it down to I'm just talking to
you know my mum
somebody who just needs to know what
they need to do today we will deal with
the more complex issues and go through
different examples in our later courses
and we will do you know how to set up a
how to set up a tenancy compliantly from
scratching into detail but this is just
really kind of basic stuff so we've been
in touch with Ann Roland's who's the
head of all the the training and
compliance at when small Wells had a
fabulous conversation with her she's
really supportive and positive about
what we're doing because it supports her
at the end of the day in her role
um so but
CPD points on this particular course no
it is purely to support the learning and
training that you've already had with
nrla or rent smart whales for your
license this is now kind of a helping
quiet hand in the background saying it's
okay we've got you and
it feeds into our landlord Community or
the landlord Facebook sorry the landlord
Community Facebook group so you could do
the videos and
you know then go into the group and say
hey I've just done this course too I can
you just confirm something else it's
like a safe place to have conversations
then open conversations about I don't
understand what a D1 or the difference
between D1 and a D2 smoke alarm is yeah
you know can you explain to me again
yeah great let's get on a Facebook live
let's tell everyone in the community
what it's about let's let's talk
um like we would to our mum to explain
to our mum how what she needs to do you
see so yeah it's really important and
that's you know that's what I wanted to
do this interview because I teach a lot
of people as you know how to get into
property and we don't have
loads of Welsh investors but we do have
some uh or some investors that might be
considering investing in Wales
um and it's important to have have
people around that you can ask questions
to and be supported by and also be aware
of the changes and the regulations that
are in place and are coming in place I
mean we've been speaking for a little
while now so I guess my closing question
would be if there's one takeaway that
landlords watching this right now
you know you'd want to leave you'd want
to leave them with what would that be
yeah I I guess mine would be uh don't
bury your head in the sand it's too
costly
um not only if you bring your head in
the sand not only is there a two-month
uh panel too much rent penalty uh about
to hit you uh but landlord but tenants
can stop paying rent if the property is
not compliant it's not fit for human
habitation and that could just be you
know you haven't got a smoke alarm it
doesn't mean that it's not nice and
shiny and and looks like a nice place to
live you haven't got the certificate
that you need means it's not it's not
fit for human habitation now under the
Welsh law so don't don't bury your head
into the sand yeah I guess that's the
takeaway
yeah yeah and I'm all about action
points so my takeaway would be uh jump
online onto Facebook uh and search the
landlord community group
um and join us in there and also follow
our page for uh regular updates I know
there's an update that's just happened
yesterday so we're just
hitting that uh this evening and to
update everyone so
um yeah my my takeaway would be jump
online
um and join us on the Facebook group
that's right well I'll put a link as
well in the description to the to the
Facebook group the landlord Community uh
Hannah Sam thank you so much for sharing
and it's been really informative and
look forward to seeing you again soon
thanks very much